in periods of relative geopolitical calm
governments can save money on defense
this is known as the peace dividend the
phrase was widely used after the fall of
the Berlin Wall
when the end of the Cold War freed up
billions of dollars previously spent on
the military a growing number of
Americans are calling for a drastic
reduction in military spending and
pressure is mounting for what some are
calling a peace dividend the redirection
of military dollars towards social
programs at home
governments use the peace dividend to
spend more on public services
yeah
it's been a time of renewed hostility
between great Powers the chances of any
kind of Peace dividend start to look
vanishingly small
[Music]
foreign